[Música]
hola bienvenidos esto es kobe 19 la
semana en américa este es el espacio de
france 24 en el que hacemos un recorrido
por las noticias más destacadas a lo
largo de la semana relacionadas con la
pandemia de kobe y 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación les presento
algunos de los temas que vamos a tratar
en esta emisión vamos a hablar de el
considerable aumento de casos que están
presentando algunos países como méxico
chile y bolivia incluso en este último
país las autoridades ya anunciaron de
manera oficial que están en la quinta
ola de contagios con nuestros
corresponsales vamos a ver entonces en
detalle cuál es la situación y qué
medidas han sido adoptadas para hacer
frente a este incremento de casos en
nuestra habitual consulta vamos a
conversar con la doctora hay línea
martín ella es asesora de salud y
seguridad para la ms con ella hablaremos
de las dos nuevas variantes que están
teniendo presencia en eeuu también
hablaremos del aumento de casos del que
somos testigos en varios países de
américa latina y también hablaremos
sobre los desórdenes psiquiátricos que
dejan algunas de las secuelas del joven
19 entre esos y otros temas también
tendremos el reporte desde eeuu para
hablar del anuncio de las autoridades de
ese país ellos anunciaron que van a
levantar esa exigencia de una prueba de
pcr negativa para poder ingresar al país
también veremos en detalle esa puesta en
marcha de un plan de vacunación para las
personas menores de 5 años para los más
pequeños y la baja tasa de vacunación en
adultos que está presentando eeuu en los
últimos meses pues comenzamos y lo
hacemos entonces como es habitual con
cifras veamos entonces cómo está
avanzando la pandemia de kobe 19 en
nuestro continente les presento el
número de casos y fallecidos reportados
en los últimos 28 días en los siguientes
países comenzamos en canadá allí en los
últimos 28 días han reportado ya más de
79 mil 600 casos han fallecido más de
1300 personas en los últimos 28 días
pasamos a costa rica y los casos ya
superan los 38 mil 700 los fallecidos
superan los 81 en ecuador ya en
sudamérica el número de casos supera los
16 mil 400 los fallecidos rondan los 50
brasil una cifra bastante alta supera
los 700 21 mil 700 casos y los
fallecidos ya superan los dos mil
novecientos y terminamos en el extremo
sur de nuestro continente en las islas
malvinas allí han reportado 607 casos en
los últimos 28 días y 0 personas han
fallecido en los últimos 28 días en ese
archipiélago
pasemos ahora a nuestra habitual
consulta en esta oportunidad hemos
invitado a la doctora aileen martín ella
es asesora de salud y seguridad para la
organización mundial de la salud la oms
y es también profesora de la asignatura
de enfermedades infecciosas a ver
doctora muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros y comienzo por preguntarle por
esas dos nuevas variantes que se están
presentando en eeuu ya hay varios casos
registrados de kobe 19 de estas
variantes en ese país que sabe la
comunidad científica y médica sobre
ellas bueno vamos a empezar para
explicar que como los eeuu un país muy
grande
diferentes cantidades porcentajes de lo
que se está manifestando es de golpe
punto
4.5 o una combinación de eso y le saldo
sólo de cual estamos hablando porque son
las más nuevas que han entrado en los
eeuu y es esa esas dos 3.4 9.5 o la
primera vez que se vio en el mundo fue
en sudáfrica
producción una alta a su acción de caso
u otra otra ola de casos hay aquí por
ejemplo donde estoy ahora que es in
miami aquí en miami estamos en la ola
número 6 producida en parte por estas de
punto 4.5 y también por la p punto
2.1 2.2 perdón porque hay tantos números
y suena como si estoy hablando chino
pero piensa así como si es el nombre que
tenemos ahora por estos tipos de o micro
aunque son muy agresivos los los tres de
que ten nombrado todos son más agresivos
que todos los otros variantes que habrán
visto que son más contagioso cada
persona que se infecta produce más virus
estamos viendo en la clínica la persona
que ha tenido kobe dos tres cuatro veces
gracias a este terrible nuevo variantes
el doctor jim
y han subido los casos en el hospital
doctora precisamente por eso por eso le
va a preguntar que si es propicio en
este momento que se está disipando
alrededor del mundo estas dos variantes
que son mucho más contagiosas era
oportuno que volviéramos a la normalidad
y regresaremos a esa apertura económica
y social eliminamos el uso de las
mascarillas en la gran mayoría de los
países y también se eliminó esas
restricciones del distanciamiento social
y todas las restricciones que tuvimos a
lo largo de los picos más fuertes de la
pandemia era el momento o no
la verdad es que quitando esas
restricciones especialmente ahora que
los estados unidos empezando a
medianoche de domingo va a parar de de
requerir que las personas tengan prueba
de un negativo con estos virus es van a
ver más personas en los aviones que van
a tener cover porque hay está muy alto
en los eeuu especialmente aquí en la
florida está muy alto entonces de cada
cuatro o cinco personas uno va a tener
cover imagínate no avión viene de
personas va a haber mucho muchas
personas echando virus en el aire o sea
si uno va a viajar
aunque no hay red que no está mandado
que uno tiene que utilizar la mascarilla
una persona inteligente que se quiere
cuidar no quieren salvarse a utilizar la
mascarilla claro doctora le cambió un
poco de tema para hablar de las vacunas
precisamente las vacunas de el
coronavirus y de esta especie del cómic
19 aceleró el desarrollo de una vacuna
contra el vih
pero tal parece que el camino es todavía
muy difícil para llegar a una conclusión
que esta vacuna puede funcionar que fue
lo que nos dio el desarrollo de estas
vacunas contra el coronavirus que puede
ayudarnos a desarrollar otras vacunas
contra otras enfermedades que todavía no
tenemos cura
bueno ahí hay muchas preguntas dentro de
tu pregunta vamos a empezar para decir
que contra hobbit ya existen más de
373 diferentes vacunas en el mundo de
diferentes clasificaciones y también
moderna y piontek facer ya han producido
nuevas formas de d
de las vacunas de ellas que pueden más
directamente atacar los tipos de omicron
están circulando y eso va a ayudar mucho
también lo ve h eso es otra cosa que
estamos mirando hay otras vacunas que
los estados unidos está mirando ahora
para ver si lo va a probar y
el problema para darte una buena
respuesta es que hay tantas diferentes
vacunas y tantas variaciones de virus
que si no me haces una pregunta
específica si no te puedo dar una
respuesta específica bueno yo le
preguntaba específicamente por el caso
del vih de una vacuna que está en
desarrollo ya para el cierre doctora
para terminar esta consulta algunas de
las secuelas del hobbit largo también
que lo hemos analizado en este programa
podría incluir desórdenes psiquiátricos
según un estudio médico de la osn que se
comenta en la comunidad científica y
médica sobre este este tipo de secuelas
y de desórdenes psiquiátricos que tiene
que ver el kobe 19 y ahí el joven 19
el virus sars del cuando ataca el cuerpo
se puede integrar en muchos diferentes
tejidos humanos
incluyendo el cerebro y también
se puede mantener en ciertos tejidos por
largo tiempo y nosotros tenemos casos en
el cual sabemos que el intestino puede
durar mucho estos virus es teniendo
virus adentro del cuerpo sin resolverlo
hace efectos dramáticos a como nosotros
podemos mirar al mundo afecta a nosotros
psicológicamente afecta nos da la
capacidad
y muchas personas con estos síntomas son
que se llaman la cinta más larga de
comer tiene fatiga tienen desorientación
no le vienen bien las palabras y estos
son parte de los problemas qué
están ocurriendo
originalmente no estábamos segura si era
una consecuencia y neurológica de haber
estado enferma pero ahora hay más
estudios demostrando que la razón por
esto es que queda un poquitico de virus
adentro del cuerpo doctora martín un
gusto hablar con usted y que nos haya
aclarado estas dudas para los
televidentes de kobe 19 la semana en
américa muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado en nuestra consulta muchas
gracias
paso ahora a mostrarles cómo está
avanzando la vacunación en esto en
nuestro continente veamos entonces el
número de dosis de refuerzo por cada 100
habitantes en los siguientes países
vamos a ver comenzamos en el caribe
república dominicana allí han inoculado
21.52 dosis de refuerzo por cada 100
habitantes en colombia la cifra ya llega
a 24.30 en panamá son 38 puntos 65 las
dosis inoculadas por cada 100 habitantes
en ecuador llega a 37 punto 94 y
paraguay que es uno de los países que
están más atrás en la vacunación en
suramérica llega al
19.75 se espera que llegue a las 20
dosis por cada 100 habitantes
bueno pues ya se lo decíamos en el
avance en chile hay un aumento
considerable en el número de casos de
kobe 19 pero este país tiene también una
alta tasa de vacunación allí las
autoridades están planteándose qué hacer
para poder mitigar el impacto a nivel
hospitalario y a nivel social de este
incremento de casos vamos a saludar a
patricia luna en la ciudad de santiago
en la capital chilena para preguntarle
patricia por ese drástico aumento de los
casos de nuevo gracias por acompañarnos
en el programa hablemos de esas cifras
son las más altas desde marzo del 2021 a
qué se debe entonces este aumento
patricia
hola santi chile registraba en las
últimas 24 horas por segundo día
consecutivo en más de 11.000 casos unas
cifras que no se registraban en los
últimos tres meses un periodo en el que
tampoco los casos habían alcanzado los
casos activos se habían situado por
encima de los 40 mil según los últimos
datos del ministerio de salud los casos
se aumentaron en todas las regiones del
país un 23% los siete últimos días y
hasta un 49 por ciento en los últimos 14
días las regiones más afectadas son
tanto en la región metropolitana
valparaíso y o'higgins en el centro del
país como la región norteña de coquimbo
también la región del norte de atacama
es la que registra una mayor incidencia
de casos por cada 100.000 habitantes
esto porque puede suceder según los
expertos de el informe y kobe que se
realiza de manera conjunta entre la
universidad católica la universidad de
chile la universidad de concepción y el
ministerio de ciencia y tecnología y el
ministerio de salud de chile esto se
podría deber a una baja en la tasa de
vacunación que aunque ha sido muy alta
se situaba en torno al 81 por ciento
el mes de marzo a mediados de marzo
excitar y ahora mismo en torno a un 59
había extendido en 22 en los últimos
tres meses lo que explicaría también
este aumento significativo de casos
porque porque sabemos que la efectividad
de la vacuna desciende cada seis meses
patricia también están intensificando
allí las campañas de autocuidado para
hacer frente a este rápido incremento de
los casos sobre todo porque ustedes ya
están en invierno que se siente con
mayor fuerza en estos países del extremo
sur del continente
con más de 38 millones de personas
contagiadas desde el inicio de la
pandemia de más de 58 mil fallecidos las
autoridades siguen reforzando los
mensajes de autocuidado pero es cierto
que esto es esta última ola que se
produce en chile esta quinta ola que se
produce cuando ni siquiera la cuarta ha
llegado a su fin es decir cuando no se
produce un descenso significativo de los
casos y ya empieza a incrementarse la
positividad que en las últimas horas se
situaba en torno a un 14% una cifra
bastante alta que no se había visto en
las últimas semanas estas medidas de
llamado al autocuidado también se han
visto perjudicadas o afectadas por el
cambio de gobierno el cambio de las
autoridades que ha hecho que cambie la
forma de transmitir los mensajes y
también la frecuencia y el modo en que
los mensajes de autocuidado llegaban a
la población y también es cierto que las
autoridades sanitarias están teniendo
que lidiar en este momento con un
aumento muy significativo de las
enfermedades respiratorias y el virus
sincicial entre otros que afecta
especialmente a los niños en el país
está se incrementaron hasta un 300 79
por ciento respecto
mismo periodo del año pasado del 2021
todo esto junto al hecho de que las
preocupaciones de los chileros también
han cambiado el aumento de la
delincuencia el aumento de los precios
de la canasta básica en una ola
inflacionaria que no se vivía en el país
en los últimos 30 años ha desplazado un
poco la preocupación sobre la comida y
esto ha hecho que se relajen también las
medidas de autocuidado junto al
cansancio que se experimenta en chile
como en muchos otros lugares del mundo
patricia si hay algo en lo que se ha
destacado chile a lo largo de esta
pandemia se en la alta vacunación están
allí también poniendo en marcha nuevos
programas incluso ya compraron un nuevo
lote de casi 500.000 dosis de diferentes
vacunas como va la vacunación allí
así el chino sigue recibiendo cientos de
miles de dosis de vacunas de manera
regular y las cifras de vacunación son
impresionantes recordemos que en esto ha
sido el líder no sólo en américa latina
sino también en el mundo se han
administrado más de 57 millones de dosis
según los últimos datos del ministerio
de salud la cobertura de dos dosis en la
población objetivo de 15 2 millones de
chilenos respecto a los 19 millones de
chilenos que existen es de un casi un 94
por ciento sin embargo es verdad que las
cifras van bajando en las
administraciones de la tercera dosis en
la que se ha administrado 15
aproximadamente un poco más de 14
millones casi 15 millones de dosis
frente a los 8 millones de la cuarta
dosis que se han administrado hasta el
momento esto ha hecho que las
autoridades llamen y hagan un refuerzo a
que la gente vaya a vacunarse de esta
cuarta dosis implementando un parche de
movilidad que caduca que ha caducado
a principios de junio si uno no tiene
está cuarta dosis ya administrada y que
impide que mucha gente en esta temporada
de invierno en que hace frío no pueda
acceder al interior de restaurantes a
espectáculos a teatros esta ha sido una
medida he hecho que los vacunatorios a
finales de mayo serían llenos porque
muchas personas no querían perder este
pase de movilidad pero aún así cuando el
paso de movilidad se hizo efectivo sí
que las cifras de notaron que había un
más de un millón y medio de personas que
perdieron su pase de movilidad es decir
que no se administraron esta cuarta
dosis de la vacuna que podría estar en
la causa de también el incremento de
casos que se vive en el país
patricia muchas gracias por este
completísimo reporte desde la ciudad de
santiago la capital chilena nos vamos
ahora hasta el vecino perú en este país
han detectado ya varios casos de nuevos
linajes de kobe 19 y también han tomado
medidas para combatir la viruela del
mono francisco zacarías desde el hima
nos va a contar más francisco gracias
por acompañarnos hoy en el programa lo
estaba mencionando detectaron ya casos
de linajes debe apuntó 4.5 de omicron
son siete peruanos que dicen las
autoridades porque no descartan allí
tampoco un incremento en los casos de
kobe 19
hola santiago el ministerio de salud de
este país detectó los linajes
descendientes de omicron ve a 4 y ve a
56 casos se hallaron en lima y 1 en la
región ancash ninguno de los infectados
han presentado síntomas graves ni han
requerido hospitalización sin embargo
las autoridades sanitarias no descartan
que haya más casos expertos del
instituto nacional de salud revelan que
de los siete casos encontrados tres
contagios de linaje ve a cuatro son
independientes es decir llegaron a perú
por tres vías distintas las autoridades
también informaron que en las últimas
semanas se han registrado contagios
focalizados del coi 19 entre distritos
de lima y no descartan que el incremento
de casos esté ligado a estos linajes
existe preocupación en los especialistas
porque de los 116 linajes descendientes
de omicron que existen en el mundo 36
han sido hallados en perú y de estos
había 4 bea 5 así como ve a 2.12 punto 1
son los que generan temor
por eso el desafío del sector salud en
esta nación es impulsar la vacunación en
más peruanos continuar el monitoreo del
comportamiento de las variantes virales
y su repercusión
epidemiológica sin francisco es que
estas dos variantes son muy contagiosas
no lo comentaba la doctora martín hace
algunos minutos le pregunto ahora por la
viruela del mono en perú ya comenzaron a
fortalecer la capacidad de respuesta
ante posibles casos en ese país y hay
cinco hospitales preparados para brindar
ya una atención exclusiva para esa
enfermedad que más han hecho de las
autoridades
pero ya se encuentra listo para
responder el arribo de la viruela del
mono las autoridades han dispuesto de
cinco hospitales el himen callado para
atender a los pacientes diagnosticados
con esta enfermedad cada hospital cuenta
con un protocolo de preparación y
respuesta para prevenir y reducir el
impacto en la población los nosocomios
están equipados con salas de aislamiento
para adultos y niños en las que se
albergará a posibles pacientes
diagnosticados del monkeypox el
ministerio de salud asegura que los
ambientes han sido implementados con
todas las medidas de bioseguridad y que
el personal sanitario fue capacitado
para brindar una atención oportuna y
cuidado especializado a los pacientes
las autoridades han establecido la línea
113 para que las personas que presenten
síntomas reciban información y sean
derivadas a establecimientos de salud
más cercanos jorge lópez ministro de
salud de este país afirmó que su sector
se encuentra alerta y vigilante para
atender los casos que se pudiesen
presentar
francisco como si ya el panorama no
fuera lo suficientemente complicado así
el personal de salud va a convocar a una
huelga nacional si el gobierno no le
paga sus obras complementarias de
trabajo son pagos que debían haber
recibido en enero del 2022 estamos
hablando de unos 70.000 trabajadores con
toda razón el reclamo
santiago la federación médica dio un
ultimátum al ministerio de salud y al
ministerio de economía para que cancelen
las deudas correspondientes al pago de
horas extras a cerca de 70 mil
trabajadores de salud durante la crisis
por la pandemia del cob y 19 el premio
de un plazo de 10 días para que el
gobierno de pedro castillo cumpla con lo
exigido de lo contrario los médicos
convocarán a una huelga nacional los
galenos revelan que el gobierno peruano
emitió dos decretos de urgencia a los
años 2021 y 2022 que los autorizaba a
trabajar horas complementarias para
evitar el déficit de personal en
momentos críticos ellos cumplieron la
labor pero desde comienzos de este año
no han recibido el pago que les
corresponde y cuando reclaman les dicen
que no hay dinero la confederación
señaló que el pago no sólo compete a
médicos sino también enfermeras
obstetras y otros profesionales de salud
que estuvieron en primera línea
combatiendo al sars cop 2 francisco
gracias por este reporte y veremos cómo
se desarrolla esa negociación entre los
médicos peruanos y las autoridades de
salud
le veníamos haciendo seguimiento al
aumento de casos en bolivia pues ya las
autoridades decretaron que están
oficialmente en la quinta ola de
contagio de kobe 19 vamos a conversar
entonces con mehdi vacas desde la ciudad
de la paz para conocer allí más detalles
mary gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
kobe 19 la semana en américa ya
oficialmente lo decía yo están ya en la
en la quinta ola lo anunció el gobierno
boliviano que están haciendo para poder
hacer frente a esta situación
así es el gobierno de luisa se ha
declarado oficialmente la llegada de la
quinta ola de kobe 19 a bolivia luego de
cuatro semanas de incremento sostenido
de los casos positivos de coronavirus en
los últimos días se han registrado más
de 400 casos diarios en todo el país las
ciudades más afectadas son santa cruz
cochabamba y la paz lo paradójico del
caso es que en medio de la emergencia
sanitaria los médicos de bolivia han
estado cumpliendo una serie de paros
escalonados por ejemplo y han cumplido
un paro de 24 horas otro de 48 horas y
tienen previsto para la próxima semana
cumplir una paralización de actividades
de 72 horas y no descartan declarar la
huelga indefinida los médicos están
pidiendo al gobierno atención a una
serie de demandas entre ellas el
incremento de los ítems en el sector de
salud mayor equipamiento para enfrentar
justamente la quinta ola y el pago de
indemnizaciones a las víctimas del
sector salud que han perecido durante la
pandemia
no ha querido dialogar con los
dirigentes médicos pues considera que
sus demandas son absolutamente políticas
y ha señalado que ellos están fracasando
en su demanda y también en su medida de
presión buenas discrepancias entre
médicos autoridades tal cual como pasa
en el vecino pero también mary llama
mucho la atención que allí en bolivia
están reforzando la oxigenoterapia para
poder enfrentar precisamente esa quinta
ola de kobe 19 en qué consiste este plan
si el ministro de salud jason ausa ha
iniciado la entrega de equipamiento a
diferentes centros de salud del país en
este marco ha dejado en la ciudad de la
paz un total de 60 equipos de
oxigenoterapia de un total de 400 que se
van a repartir en todo el país explicó
que estos equipos van a permitir mejorar
la oxigenación de los pacientes de kobe
19 para evitar que lleguen a las
unidades de terapia intensiva por otro
lado la autoridad ha pedido a los
bolivianos aunar esfuerzos para
enfrentar esta crisis sanitaria y evitar
la confrontación en clara alusión a los
médicos que mantienen estas medidas de
presión
mary quinta ola de contagio y uno de los
mejores mecanismos hasta ahora así lo
han demostrado en su efectividad es la
vacunación como avanza la vacunación
entonces en este país
las autoridades han pedido prácticamente
están implorando a los ciudadanos
bolivianos que acudan a los centros de
salud a completar sus esquemas de
vacunación sin embargo estos centros se
han visto vacíos y sin ninguna fila pero
sí con muchas vacunas a la espera de la
gente según datos oficiales hasta ahora
alrededor del 75% de la población se ha
colocado la primera dosis en contra del
cob y 19 el 68% ha accedido a la segunda
dosis y sólo el 13 por ciento se ha
colocado la tercera dosis contra el
coronavirus sin embargo lo que se
mantiene con normalidad en bolivia son
las actividades masivas e incluso
festivas durante estos días por ejemplo
en la ciudad de la paz se desarrolla la
popular y masiva fiesta del gran poder
que saca a los bailarines a las calles
quienes tienen autorización para danzar
sin barbijo pero eso sí deben presentar
su carnet de vacunación entretanto las
actividades escolares se mantienen de
manera presencial en todo el país aunque
algunas pocas unidades educativas han
suspendido porque se han presentado
casos de kobe 19 meriva acá en la paz
muchas gracias por este reporte desde
bolivia pasamos ahora entonces a eeuu
recientemente las autoridades de ese
país levantaron la exigencia de una pcr
negativa para poder entrar a este país
también allí hemos visto un aumento de
las variantes ya las estamos mencionando
son sus variantes que ya representan
casi el 13 por ciento de los casos y van
a habilitar la vacunación para los
menores de 5 años para hablar sobre este
tema saludamos santo nivel si él está en
esta oportunidad desde la ciudad de los
ángeles que está allí cubriendo la
cumbre de las américas pero saca un
tiempito también para colaborar nos aquí
en kobe 19 la semana en américa y
reportar nos estas importantes
decisiones y anuncios del gobierno de
estados unidos anthony gracias para
acompañarnos dos variantes que van
ganando terreno 13 por ciento de los
casos detectados en este país son debe
apuntó 4.5 que más dicen las autoridades
hola santiago así es son dos variantes
relativamente nuevas de la cepa o un
micro en el coronavirus son como
apuntaban la bea 4 y la bea 5 y según
datos oficiales están ganando terreno en
las últimas semanas en eeuu en un
momento en el que el país ha vuelto
prácticamente a la total normalidad a
pesar de que hay un repunte de la
pandemia y también cuando la casa blanca
ya ha anunciado que va a eliminar el
requisito de presentar una prueba
negativa de coronavirus para entrar al
país pero esas nuevas cepas según los
centros para el control de enfermedades
estas dos variantes son las responsables
del alza de infecciones en sudáfrica
durante los meses de abril y mayo ya
suponen un 13% de los casos detectados
en el país en norteamérica no hace solo
una semana estas variantes serán
responsables de únicamente un 6% de los
casos y hace un mes apenas tenían
presencia en estados unidos lo que
apunta a que su expansión se está
produciendo a un ritmo muy alto sin
embargo el gobierno de eeuu considera
que la pandemia está controlada y es por
eso que como comentaba ha decidido
eliminar esa medida impuesta en de 2021
que obligaba a cualquier persona ya
fuera nacional o extranjera a presentar
una prueba negativa a la medida entrará
en vigor a partir de este domingo
aumenta lo mencionamos en programas
anteriores que el gremio de las
aerolíneas había pedido a la casa blanca
que por favor eliminar esa restricción
para poder permitir un crecimiento más
rápido del sector aeronáutico en eeuu
importante esta semana ese anuncio
anthony de las autoridades de comenzar a
vacunar a los niños oa menores de edad
de cinco años hacia abajo contra el kobe
19 y por eso compró millones de dosis de
vacunas como va a avanzar ese plan que
es lo que tienen pensado hacer
pues sí ya las autoridades sanitarias de
eeuu han recibido millones de pedidos
para las vacunas contra el kopi 19
destinadas a niños pequeños antes de la
posible autorización federal que está
previsto para la semana entrante según
han informado funcionarios de la casa
blanca el gobierno ha permitido ya desde
la semana pasada que farmacias y otros
estados empiecen a formular pedidos y ya
hay cinco millones de dosis disponibles
la mitad son de facer y la otra mitad de
modernas de los dos millones y medio de
dosis de facer disponibles ya se han
pedido cerca de un millón y medio y unas
850.000 de modernas a los niños menores
de cinco años conforman el último grupo
que queda por recibir vacunas aquí en
eeuu unos 20 millones de niños serían
elegibles para recibir la inoculación si
el gobierno lo acaba autorizando habrá
que ver si las vacunas se usan porque
una encuesta reciente indicó que apenas
uno de cada cinco padres iría
inmediatamente a vacunar a sus hijos
aparte de eso las autoridades están
decepcionadas por el bajo número de
niños mayores que han ido a ponerse las
dosis a pesar de que las pueden recibir
en cualquier punto del país menos de un
tercio un tercio de todos los niños de
entre 5 y 12 años se han puesto al menos
las dos dosis
antonio y también decepciona un poco la
tasa de vacunación entre los adultos los
adultos allí en eeuu siguen sin confiar
en la vacunación en los biológicos para
hacer frente al joven 19 que se puede
hacer
pues sí precisamente desde la cumbre de
las américas desde donde me encuentro en
estos momentos aquí en la ciudad de los
ángeles el gobierno de eeuu ha puesto de
manifiesto los problemas que ha
enfrentado el país para conseguir buenas
tasas de vacunación también lo comentaba
el presidente de facer para américa
latina que indicaba que debido a la
desinformación especialmente en eeuu y
algunas regiones de américa latina' por
muchísima gente no se ha vacunado por un
temor de que ellos según ellos es
inexistente en eeuu cerca de un 78% de
la población tiene al menos una vacuna
el 67 por ciento tiene la pauta completa
pero esas cifras van aumentando semana a
semana pero a un ritmo muy lento es la
tasa más baja de norteamérica a pesar de
que aquí fue donde llegó antes la vacuna
las autoridades sanitarias insisten en
que si el ritmo de vacunación hubiera
ido mucho más rápido se hubiera vuelto a
la normalidad
muchísimo antes claro que sí antonio y
pues muchas gracias por este reporte
anthony welsch y desde la ciudad de los
ángeles en california y nos vamos al
vecino méxico no muy lejos del estado de
california allí también están aumentando
los casos de kobe 19 vamos a ver dicen
las autoridades también no sólo el
aumento de los casos sino de la
saturación hospitalaria mario' carbonell
desde ciudad de méxico nos va a contar
más -mario gracias por conectarse con
nosotros para esta edición de kobe 19 la
semana en américa y decenas de
hospitales están registrando casi el
100% de ocupación en lugares muy
específicos de la república mexicana a
qué se debe que dicen las autoridades
si hay 36 hospitales en 19 estados de la
república que presentan ocupación al
100% en camas de hospitalización general
incluidas la ciudad de mexico o nuevo
león y jalisco que son de las tres
entidades más importantes también hay
cuatro hospitales que tienen ocupación
del 100% en camas con ventilador
mecánico no obstante digamos en el
esquema total de hospitales del país es
una cantidad muy menor la autoridad
sanitaria reporta que a nivel nacional
hay una disponibilidad de camas de
hospitalización general del 97 por
ciento y en camas de ventilador mecánico
la disponibilidad es del 99 por ciento
es cierto que digamos si bien los
contagios van al alza las defunciones y
la ocupación hospitalaria se mantiene
baja sin embargo bueno la recomendación
general es no bajar la guardia y volver
a tomar estas medidas de protección
bueno no bajar la guardia pero el tema
hospitalario no es grave no es para
alarmarse según lo indican entonces las
autoridades hablemos ahora del aumento
casos 12 estados de la república
mexicana están mostrando repuntes
considerables
así es hay un repunte de casos de kobe
19 en mexico en todo el país
efectivamente son 12 los estados con
mayor número de casos
ciudad de méxico baja california sur y
sinaloa son las entidades que encabezan
esta lista con mayor número de casos
activos y esto ha llevado a las
autoridades sanitarias a retomar la
difusión diaria de los reportes de
covite durante todo el mes de mayo se
optó por únicamente presentar un reporte
semanal de resumen del comportamiento
del cobi y ahora desde el 7 de junio
nuevamente es un reporte diario de
contagios y de fallecimientos lo que
muestran los datos es una clara
tendencia al alza se tienen días de 5000
días de seis mil hasta de 8.000
contagios cuando estas cantidades los
teníamos hace un mes pero de manera
semanal es decir había seis mil
contagios por semana ahora es cada día
en la ciudad de mexico se ha hecho un
comparativo por ejemplo al 7 de mayo
había 30 casos y el 7 de junio un mes
después 210 casos esto es un incremento
de 600 por ciento
y director del instituto mexicano del
seguro social sobre robledo es una
institución que atiende en materia de
salud a 71 millones de mexicanos informó
que es positivo a comida es decir el
virus está de nueva cuenta a la vuelta
de la esquina varió con estas cifras que
usted nos explica uno podría decir que
tal vez hay una diferencia de percepción
entre los especialistas en el tema de
infectología que ya hablan de que méxico
está en una quinta ola de contagio pero
el gobierno insiste en que no es así y
que prácticamente el kobe 19 ya
desapareció del país que hacen entonces
para enfrentar este incremento de casos
y para cambiar esa percepción
las autoridades se han mostrado un tanto
reacia a reconocer que estamos ya en
quinta ola el propio vocero de la
pandemia el responsable hugo lópez
gatell ha dicho que si hay presencia de
sub variantes de o micro pero que
persiste la que estuvo dominando durante
la cuarta ola insiste en que la
vacunación es clave sin embargo hay
otras voces autorizadas que opinan lo
contrario por ejemplo el secretario de
salud de sinaloa ha declarado ya
oficialmente quinta ola otros expertos
como el doctor alejandro macías
reconocen que la presencia de sus
variantes ve a 4 a 5 están impulsando
está quinta ola y las recomendaciones de
nueva cuenta retomar las medidas que se
habían relajado como el uso de
cubrebocas varias gracias por este
reporte desde mexico y vamos ahora a dar
un vistazo a otras noticias destacadas
en redes comenzamos con esta publicación
de nuestros colegas de swiss info ellos
titulan o ms faltan informaciones clave
para entender cómo empezó la pandemia la
organización indicó que son requeridos
más estudios en personas animales
incluso en el medio ambiente en china
lugar en donde fueron a darse a conocer
los primeros casos de esta enfermedad el
informe dice que según la información
epidemiológica y genética del origen del
cómic 19 sería de origen animal los
virus más cercanos fueron registrados en
murciélagos en china y en laos en 2013 y
en 2020 y regresan los vuelos desde las
islas malvinas hacia chile y argentina-
a partir del 2 de julio este
archipiélago que está ubicado en el
extremo sur de nuestro continente
después de dos años de cierre por la
pandemia volverá a tener vuelos
comerciales desde su capital la ciudad
de puerto stanley hacia las ciudades de
punta arenas y santiago en chino en
chile así como una vez por semana a la
ciudad de río gallegos en argentina
durante el confinamiento estas islas
estuvieron conectadas con el resto del
mundo a través de solamente un vuelo
semanal de la real fuerza aérea
británica procedente del reino unido-
esto significa también que se reactiva
la industria turística en malvinas
y este fue nuestro resumen de noticias
aquí en kobe 19 la semana en américa ya
lo saben la emergencia continúa
continúen cuidándose por favor sigan
viendo france24 continua con nosotros
[Música]